j'en meurs tu as
comme presque chaque matin depuis le
début de la crise le il dit à jean
funéraire dans le val de marne vient
récupérer le cercueil d'un homme décédé
du coït 19 à l'hôpital henri mondor de
créteil au plus fort de l'épidémie
entre fin mars et mi avril son agence a
pris en charge plus de 30 décès soit
trois fois plus que l'année dernière à
la même période sur place comme pour
tous les décès dûs aux couronnes à virus
le corps enveloppés dans des sacs
hermétiques est ensuite présenté à la
famille dans un cercueil fermé
pour shi relais qui n'avait pas vu son
père depuis son admission à l'hôpital
c'est très dur de ne pas pouvoir voir
une dernière fois son visage
malheureusement on n'a pas pu se
recueillir ni le voir il ya là on
restera non dire non vie on n'a pas le
visage on voit pas enfin on sait même
pas si son corps est déjà dans le sac
on est vraiment dans le vide total et la
situation à la crise sanitaire est
vraiment puisque des plots rappelons
nous qu'en fait c'est on est perdu et on
peut pas on peut pas le voir pour nous
il n'y a pas de deuil
le corps du père de charles ix sera
entreposé pendant une dizaine de jours à
la morgue provisoire installé à rungis
pour délester les chambres funéraires a
submergé des hôpitaux là bas seuls trois
membres de la famille à la fois peuvent
entrer ensemble pour voir le cercueil du
défunt
le corps du père dechy relais sera
ensuite incinéré mais en l'absence de la
famille au plus et les dispersions matin
le recueillement est en effet interdit
dans les crématoriums pendant le
confinement
vous êtes premier à 25 je ne sais pas
j'ai personnellement j'avais mis fin
plus à l'envolée de son ca m ça va être
le gardien du cimetière qui va qui va
gérer pour les familles les obsèques tel
qu organisé durant la crise sanitaire
sont ainsi particulièrement difficile à
vivre
je serai dans la fleur dans la tiédeur
du toit caen la bri limitée à une
vingtaine de personnes tout au plus les
animations ne leur permettent pas non
plus de vivre pleinement le deuil la
colère de la colère oui de la colère
beaucoup de colère parce que c'est la
façon on n'a pas pu le voir pendant plus
d'un mois à l'hôpital
on ne pouvait pas s'en occuper on
pouvait rien faire on ne pouvait rien
faire il appelait même pas fallu les
appeler fallait tout faire nous-mêmes et
l'autre côté nos marques et et c'est
tout c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire est
même mort on pouvait pas le voir on a
bien sûr fait fermer si c'est pas
quelqu'un qui avait trois enfants neuf
petits enfants ses fans façon glauque et
et traite les gens comme des chiffres
ces contraintes imposées au
recueillement des familles endeuillées
ont aussi des natures et l'activité des
entreprises de pompes funèbres qui ne
sont plus en mesure de leur proposer un
véritable accompagnement dans ces
moments difficiles
finalement on leur présente lors c'est
le cercueil qu'arrivé au cimetière ou
pas du tout au crématorium et l'arrivée
au cimetière bas en plus de ça on en
laisse juste faire un adieu sur un
cercueil qui est fermé pour elle c'est
difficile on le sent que c'est quand
même très difficile que ça sera dur plus
tard de de rattraper ça le 11 mai
certaines restrictions vont être
assouplies
outre la réouverture des cimetières la
présence des familles sera de nouveau
autorisé durant les crémations
les obsèques seront elles toujours
limité à 20 personnes